Katheryn Winnick has become a breakout star
thanks to her portrayal of legendary shieldmaiden
Lagertha in the hit series Vikings.
But Vikings is far from the first role Winnick
has nabbed.
In fact, the Canadian actress has been appearing
on film and in TV shows for nearly two decades.
Here's a look at why Lagertha from Vikings
looks so familiar.
Oh, Canada
Before making the jump to Hollywood, Winnick
earned her stripes appearing in a pair of
TV shows north of the border.
In 1999, she landed her screen debut as sorority
girl Suzie in the paranormal drama PSI Factor:
Chronicles of the Paranormal.
And later that year, she joined the cast of
the high school comedy Student Bodies, where
she played Holly Benson, girlfriend of main
character Cody Miller.
Hey, everyone has to start somewhere!
Victimized
Starting in 2002, Winnick began a long and
lucrative side career as a professional victim
on both the Law and Order and CSI franchises.
All told, she's appeared once on Law & Order,
twice on Law & Order: Criminal Intent, and
managed a CSI trifecta by appearing on CSI:Miami,
CSI:New York, and the original CSI:Crime Scene
Investigation.
Over those six appearances, she's managed
to do everything from getting locked in a
basement by a psycho to being impaled on a
tree.
That's a tough way to make a living.
​Trump Unauthorized
Back in 2005, Winnick played none other than
Donald Trump's first wife Ivana in a TV movie
called Trump Unauthorized.
Variety was less than enthused about Winnick's
work, saying her accent sounded closer to
something from the Rocky and Bullwinkle Show
than it did Czech-born Ivana Trump.
The Donald himself gave his approval, however,
saying that "Having a two-hour movie on network
television while you're still living is sort
of wild, you're supposed to be gone for that
to happen."
​Failure to Launch
Winnick got her first big break with a minor
role in Matthew McConaughey's 2006 romantic
comedy Failure to Launch, a film about a man
in his mid-30s who refuses to leave the comfort
of his mother's home until he meets the right
woman.
That woman was played by Sarah Jessica Parker,
not Winnick, but Winnick told ShowBizMonkey
that she would happy to one day take on the
lead role, saying she'd "love to do a romantic
comedy, 100 percent.
You know, they're fun.
Get me a good co-star, someone cute."
​Killers
Winnick got to live out the fantasy of every
person who bought a ticket to see 2010 hitman-and-wife
rom-com Killers when she kicked leading man
Ashton Kutcher through a glass door.
Most of Winnick's other scenes as Kutcher's
secretary, Vivian, were forgettable, but this
one is notable for being the first time we
got to see the action chops that would later
make Winnick famous in Vikings.
​Love and Other Drugs
Killers wasn't the only romcom Winnick appeared
in during 2010, as she also had a role in
Love and Other Drugs, where she got toc make
out with Christina Fandino in front of an
awestruck Jake Gyllenhaal.
Winnick told reporters that it wasn't just
a cheap stunt.
"This movie is definitely for men and women.
Not only do you have that sexiness throughout
the movie, but it's a female character that
girls can aspire to be…"
Unfortunately, the film didn't take off, and
was another in a string of duds for Winnick.
​Bones
Winnick met with Bones producers in 2010 about
the "controversial" recurring role of Hannah
Burley, a journalist that FBI agent Seeley
Booth rescues from a terrorist situation in
Afghanistan.
They warned her that fans might take a disliking
to her for coming between Booth and Brennan.
"They definitely want the two of them, Brennan
and Booth, together, so I know I'm gonna be
in some hot water."
Winnick signed on anyway for a memorable arc
that ended with her turning down Booth's marriage
proposal, allowing him to get back with Brennan
like the fans wanted.
"For a bone, what was your favorite part of
'Bones'?"
"Booth.
And uh, Bones, obviously."
"Yeah, obviously the bones."
​Stand Up Guys
In the 2012 crime caper Stand Up Guys, Winnick
played a brothel worker named Oxana.
Though the film was a flop, the opportunity
to work with some of her favorite actors was
a dream come true for Winnick, who told CraveOnline,
"I really wanted to work with Al Pacino.
I'm a huge fan and also love Christopher Walken
and Alan Arkin.
I wanted to share the screen with them and
was excited just to be in the same room as
them."
​The Art of the Steal
Chances are you probably missed the 2014 ensemble
comedy The Art of the Steal, which starred
Kurt Russell as an art thief and featured
Winnick - sporting black hair this time around
- as his girlfriend Lola.
Winnick probably wishes she had missed it
as well, considering it was a critical and
box office mess.
Oh well, you can't win 'em all.
​Person of Interest
The cult favorite CBS series Person of Interest
got a visit from a person of particular interest
to Vikings fans when Winnick guest-starred
in 2015.
She played Frankie Wells, a bounty hunter
relentlessly stalking her brother's killer.
It's just the kind of high octane, kick-butt
role Winnick is perfect in.
Our advice to Winnick: leave the lame romcoms
to Katherine Heigl and stick to punching people
in the face.
It's what your fans love!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!